hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 2 video
probably like the best episode of
Walking Dead I've ever seen I can't
remember the last time off the top of my
head that the B team has such an
exciting story like they did an amazing
job you have to remember that all the
big hitters are dealing with the super
pack right now which we actually didn't
see during this episode so let's just go
ahead and get into it there's so much
stuff to go on and I'll explain who that
new character is Denise Cloyd she's
right out of the comics just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet and new round of the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so here we go starting with top 5
WTF moments number 5 meet Denise Cloyd
she is the new doctor same story in the
comics that gets his ripped right off
the page
she explains she has medical training
she was gonna be a surgeon but then the
apocalypse happened so she's just trying
to do the best that she can in the
adorable thing about her she I mean her
name is Merritt Wever in real life
that's the name of the actress is that
she is a coward just like Eugene they
just seem like they're tailor-made for
each other like both of them have a
natural tendency towards cowardice but
they're both very useful once they get
out of that fear hump like once they get
over the initial fear of whatever
situation is happening probably my
favorite Denise moment though was it
wasn't like the awkward introduction it
was at the end when everyone was
starting to feel the grief of what had
happened and Tara is slowly walking away
and says I just actually just wanted to
remind you get the brain denise is still
experiencing the shock of losing the
patient on the table and the craziness
was going on and Tara just like slips it
in just really casually like don't don't
forget to get her brain what I'm
expecting from her character is that
she'll survive as long as they have the
safe zone so if they end up destroying
the safe zone in this season then all
bets are off
but it seems like she'll be on the show
at least through episode 8 usually when
the Walking Dead blows places up like
big locations it's either premieres
midseason finales or the regular season
finale on to number four though Jessie
Hulk's out and gives the wolf a giant
haircut in the chest the best thing
about this isn't the tension like the
moment before the storm before
everything goes crazy it's when she's in
the middle of it in her eyes go all
crazy and Ron walks up really quietly
behind her and just watches his mom stab
the [ __ ] out of this wolf he is never
going to cut his hair again Alexander
Breckenridge the actress is a series
regular I think so
I'm expecting that Jesse's gonna be
around so they might have to change her
plot from the comics there in the middle
of no way out that's like the the comic
that they're working through right now
in the TV show so they could do her
story from the comics but it seems like
they might end up changing it those of
you that have read the comics do you
think that this encounter that Jesse had
her killing the wolf is evidence that
they've completely changed her storyline
from the comics or do you think that
that is still coming down the road
please use spoiler tags just in case
people don't want to know what ends up
happening to Jesse in the comics
we actually learned a little bit more
about what's going on with her character
when she's talking to Ron in the early
parts of the episode but before the [ __ ]
hit the fan
mostly that she's still on pretty good
terms with Rick even though she
acknowledges that things are kind of
weird it was kind of hard to tell where
they stood after that black and white
flashback in episode 1 like is she just
like completely just gonna push him away
or are they gonna continue to be close
so it seems like Jesse and Rick might
still be a thing but usually that's the
kiss of death for characters on TV show
like once once you enter into a loving
relationship you turn into one of the
best boyfriends you get marked for death
on to number three though Enid's intro I
would say this is on par with Bob's
intro from the second half of season 4
there was an episode that just had this
really long Bob introduction where you
saw what happened to him before he met
the survivors just like being an
alcoholic walking down the road to music
the JSS turns out to stand for just
survive somehow it does kind of sound
like something that a teenager would
come up with just like a really simple
phrase I thought it would either be that
or her original name before the
apocalypse it is if Enid was the name
that she gave herself after the
apocalypse started but my favorite thing
about Enid wasn't those scenes with Carl
I mean that was that was kind of
touching to see Carl get those moments
you don't see a lot of really big Carl
scenes but now that Chandler Riggs is
slowly getting older I think you're
gonna see more and more of that they're
gonna start giving him more scenes but
it was when she found the turtle and she
just ate it like he would eat a crab
just cracking the shell open and just
picking the bits out totally gross but
it was so funny to see her write jss
with the bones on the ground like the
awkward kind of funny where you're
laughing but you're also a little bit
scared that's one of the awesome things
about The Walking Dead like he can make
you laugh at like really awkward moments
that you later feel bad about like oh I
shouldn't be laughing about this someone
is getting their head chopped in half
speaking of which on my number two
moment jedi morgan versus the wolves so
there was this really met
thing going on in the episode that I'm
gonna spread across by number two and
number one moments where it was kind of
putting forth Carole's ideology versus
Morgan's ideology Morgan has this really
good speech where he's talking to the
wolf where he's like you can't continue
on this way or else you're gonna die
like violence will only breed more
violence you you live by the sword you
die by the sword so we're only in
episode two just expect that theme to
continue those competing ideologies I
know their conversation made it seem
like Morgan had been a wolf previously
like the the wolf seemed like he knew
him really well like oh my god it's you
you're that guy it's totally possible
they could have known each other for an
extended period of time what I thought
that the wolf was referring to was the
season five finale when we see Morgan in
the flashback and he's travelling along
and runs into that wolf that he later
was not able to kill and that's another
thing too we need to debate in the
comments do you think that you know
because of the way they were positioning
Carroll and Morgan in this episode that
Morgan killed that wolf at the end you
can't do it but you should have done it
before so I think the implication is is
that he ran him off like that wolf is
still alive and he will continue to be a
villain for the next couple of episodes
in season five I think I said in my
episode 1 video but there's always two
different kinds of conflicts of The
Walking Dead there's conflict inside the
group like these two competing
ideologies of Carroll versus Morgan's
philosophy and then you have conflict
outside the group with you know with
actual villains that are trying to stab
you in the face the wolves that survived
in this episode the ones that Morgan ran
off along with this guy might end up
being that external conflict you know in
addition to the super pack which is
totally still coming but finally out of
my number one WTF moment rambo carroll
blows her cover is a Stepford wife as
much as Morgan had some amazing scenes
in this episode playing off of Carol
this was really Carol's episode and I
know I said this is kind of like the
b-team like this is like the b-team
episode because all the a players we're
out dealing with the super pack but
carol is like an a team member like one
of the hard hitters disguised as a B
team member so I'm actually really
interested to see how the rest of the
safe zone deals with Carol now that they
know that she's a confirmed badass like
oh you know how to use all these weapons
and you know how to use camo and you're
not afraid to kill people on site or
leave people to die like like father
Gabriel for instance that was
interesting she just walked right past
was like he's fine she was totally ready
to let him die
in the end of the episode when she's
sitting on her porch with those
cigarettes the cigarette thing that's
like a whole other thing we have to talk
about that was so funny
just the way people's conversations
inform successive scenes like the
cigarettes tracing the path of the
cigarettes but I feel like they left
things ambiguous on purpose like you
know she was kind of crying over that
cigarette she saw the a that kind of
reminded her of train-car
a then she passed Morgan on the street
like they were walking down each other's
paths that's why I thought that Morgan
might have killed the wolf because he
walked down the path that Carol had
walked down but I think they just wanted
you to feel like Carol was considering
what Morgan was saying like if I
continue down this path then I'm going
to die violence will meet with more
violence but the real reason that you
have to admire up Carol is that even
more so than Rick she's so much more
ready than Rick to give up her humanity
to protect the people that she cares
about Rick kind of does that but it
still takes him a little while to get
going in any given situation he's still
pauses to give thought
Carol is just like it's automatic the
minute she sees cigarette woman get the
hatchet buried in her face she
immediately activates a Rambo mode and I
just I love the camo that she was using
to the other Wolves thought that she was
one of their friends because she took
the clothes off of one of their bodies
so if you want to explain this episode
to someone who doesn't watch The Walking
Dead just say there's a whole bunch of
characters they were doing spring
cleaning they were making spring
cleaning casseroles it's like the show
is shaking the tree and getting some of
the cast members to fall down freshening
things up even though technically it's
the fall you so you can't really call it
spring cleaning let me know in the
comments though what was your favorite
moment and where do you think that Enid
is going like do you think that we'll
see her again or she just she gone
forever and what do you think is gonna
happen with the super pack next week
because they're still coming I mean I
expected them to just walk up all like
hey what's going on we heard there was a
party just remember that the walkers are
relatively slow even though there are
billion of them so we see Rick running
down the street so they'll probably get
back to the safe zone to tell everyone
hey there is a [ __ ] ton of walkers
headed this way I will be really
interested to see how they top episode
two though episode 2 felt so great and
it was that much better because it was
the B characters like whenever Daryl's
on screen whenever Rick's around you
expect badass things to happen because
they're badass characters when you have
people like Carl you have like all the
lesser characters you know you just you
don't expect quite as much so when they
deliver
like this you're just like oh my god
this is amazing so giant high-fives best
episode of season stakes so far
hopefully things get better I would be
really disappointed if it all went
downhill from here
but what's gonna happen tomorrow is this
because there's a new Star Wars trailer
that's gonna be my video tomorrow so my
Walking Dead Q&A will post later in the
week like it has the last couple weeks I
feel like if you're gonna bump things it
might as well be for a new Star Wars
footage so everybody freaked out that
video won't post till later in the night
but if you have ESPN they're gonna air
it on TV during Monday Night Football on
ESPN that is so while you guys wait for
new Star Wars footage you can click here
for the last episode seventy so that I
posted earlier today and you can click
here for all my other Walking Dead
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow